[Musique]
je t'avais dit que je voulais aller à ce
festival en suède n'ont pas dit que ce
serait cool d'y aller ouais et là j'ai
l'opportunité de le faire alors j'ai
envie d'y aller c'est juste que j'aurais
voulu que tu me prévienne c'est tout
[Musique]
elle a besoin de voir un psy tu veux te
sortir de cette relation trop bizarre
depuis plus d'un an
n'oublie pas toutes les magnifiques
suédoise que vous allez rencontrer en
juin
ok encore elle sans déconner ouais mon
coeur qu'est-ce qui se passe
oui ça m'a vraiment fait de la peine
d'apprendre qui s'était passé
excuse moi
j'ai proposé at any venir en suède
chérissent quelqu'un d'endurer question
a dit que vous alliez un événement oui
c'est un festival de folie cérémonie
spéciale avec des déguisements
c'est alarmant
chinon bienvenue et joyeux 8 somme à ce
qu il est 15h 21h
c'est pas normal le ciel est bleu c'est
comme ça ici à 21h
[Musique]
ça fait combien de temps que vous êtes
ensemble un peu plus de trois heures et
demie quatre ans ouais tu en penses quoi
on dirait un autre monde
grand jour de mardi il faut la trouille
c'est quoi ça des propriétés spéciales
non ce qui se passe
vous juste pour solitude de table
habituel je veux [ __ ] le camp
mais c'est hors de question qu'est-ce
qui se passe
en quoi tu nous a proposé de venir
je savais c'est pour ça que tant qu'on
pape
on ne le fait que tous les 90 ans
j'étais tellement content que vous venir
[Musique]